all right so I'm breaking news to tell
you about now and there's been another
earthquake in Turkey one person has been
reported dead in karamamarash and more
buildings have been destroyed the
magnitude 5.6 Quay came three weeks
after two major earthquakes that killed
at least 50 000 people across turkey and
Syria let's bring in Theresa ball who's
live for us in gaziantep in southern
turkey so another earthquake in just the
last hour bring us up to speed with the
latest Teresa
well the earthquake was also felt here
we're in the center of gazianteb right
where those who have been affected by
the earthquakes that happened on
February 6 are living now inside hands
and it generated once again fear and
anguish among so many other things the
information that we have is that the
epicenter was in malate it's about three
hours away from where we are several
buildings were were destroyed the mayor
there said that Turkish Emergency
Services have deployed search and rescue
operation to see whether anyone has been
trapped in the rubble the other City
affected was that's about one hour away
from where we are we know that a factory
collapsed at least one person was killed
there and three others were injured and
this is ongoing we're hearing almost
every day of aftershocks and and
earthquakes not such as this one but
certainly this is something that has
been ongoing it's terribly upsetting for
those who have survived many of those
living here their homes have been
destroyed by others they they had their
homes they have been damaged but they do
not want to go back there precisely
because of the aftershocks and this type
of earthquakes that are being felt
throughout the region yeah more anguish
for the people there it's been three
weeks now Teresa since those two
powerful earthquakes across turkey and
Syria how are people coping three weeks
on
well this earthquakes and aftershocks
that are still ongoing after those two
big ones that happened almost three
weeks ago are suddenly unsettling for
people here but they're still struggling
on a day-to-day basis wherever you go in
this part of the country you're seeing
tents like this one with people that
have been living there for three weeks
and they're telling us that yes they
have received some tents they have
received some water and food but they
don't know what is going to happen with
their life we also know that the Turkish
government has given people some cash
handouts and assisted it's around 500
dollars around a million people have
received that amount of money but still
many of the people we've been talking to
here are telling us that it is not
enough we just spoke to a woman for
example that says that five families are
living just inside one to ten at one
tenth and you can imagine you know how
difficult it is to continue in those
conditions the Turkish government is
saying that it's hoping to build at
least 200 000 homes in one year that is
putting lots of effort to assist the
population but still it is an enormous
Challenge and another challenge right
now is uh what's happening with a rubble
in all this part of the country around
200 million tons of rubble will have to
be removed earlier uh this this week we
were in a city there where they're
making lots of effort to get the rubble
out of the city so that the rebuilding
process May begin
Rubble dust and loss are everywhere in
Southeastern turkey these days
authorities have already started to
clear the rubble
but nevermind says she cannot forget
what she has lost and comes here every
day where her home once stood
we removed my mother and father from the
rubble only my father was alive every
day I come to the same place to see if I
can find their belongings just to have a
memory
clearing away the mountains of rubble is
a daunting task because it is everywhere
in this part of the country
trucks have unloaded tons of rubble all
around this area creating these
mountains that you can see right behind
me removing the debris from the center
of the city is a huge challenge
according to the United Nations the
volume of the rubble that needs to be
removed they've all put together would
cover an area of around 100 square
kilometers
or over 18 000 football fields the
Turkish government says the rubble will
be removed and processed without harming
the environment and the people
but environmental groups have expressed
fears about possible contamination
there is also health concerns about the
presence of affectos a mineral that
could cause cancer which was permitted
to use in Turkey until 2014.
this map shows that asbestos was
detected in the areas affected by the
earthquakes
in the city of Hasa patients are showing
up non-stop at this field Hospital set
up by the Indonesian government
many are coming for regular checkups but
others with respiratory difficulties
Dr coronarindawan says the cleanup
process is crucial to prevent disease
people must be covered by a
must be given the the mass if there's a
community
surrounding the rumble before they start
to clean the rumble of the cleaning of
the rambles makes the the dust is affect
the people
primarily of the respiratory problem
turkey is struggling to cope with a
scale of the disaster caused by the
earthquakes
removing the rubble is only the first
step of the likely many challenges ahead
well and as we the government is pushing
to remove the rubble to begin the
rebuilding process we're hearing more
information about the earthquake that
happened on this date about three hours
away from here in the city of malatia
the vice president has just said that at
least 20 buildings have collapsed 22
people have been taken to a hospital and
the situation is ongoing the Turkish
Emergency Services have been deployed
search and rescue operations around the
way and this is terribly upsetting for
people that are living in tent camps
like this one many of them have lost all
of their belongings during the
earthquake many of them have lost their
loved ones so situations such as this
one put lots of tension on the ground
lots of Anguish on the ground many
people here would like to know when
they'll be able to go back to their
normal lives there is about thank you
very much for that update and as Teresa
was saying another earthquake in
southern turkey will keep a close eye on
the situation and update you as and when
we have more information